hey lisa how are you good how are you
i'm doing good i love this movie so much
i was such a theater kid growing up so i
could totally relate to it um
i love this movie because it really
centers around the idea of just being
yourself and never giving up on your
dreams so i was curious with you uh when
you first started as an actor was there
ever a time that you just wanted to give
up that you didn't think it was actually
gonna happen
i would think you have to think that
sometimes you know like when you're
mostly getting rejected and not you know
not getting work
but it didn't last long
if i did i was like maybe i'm just not
supposed to do this it didn't last long
so that to me was the sign that that's
what i had to just keep keep doing keep
going
yeah that's amazing is this something
that you just always knew you were meant
to do
well when i was a kid i did and then i
in high school and college i went nope
that is absolutely never what i'm going
to do
i'm going i like science and yeah so i
put it away and then just picked it up
again after i graduated
oh my gosh that's amazing um the younger
cast in this movie is so good aria's
great ruby's great what was it like
working with them because they can
really hold their own
i know i'm you know they were
so professional
so happy to be there so
polite respectful of everybody there was
never one complaint you gotta pay time
you have to go to school now
okay
all right now we need this okay we need
the everything they were just okay
yeah they
i mean they just embodied they never
forgot
this is what i was so happy to get to do
and i think that gets forgotten on sets
a lot i love it when a movie everyone's
there because they want to be there and
and yeah this was that
100
so it was really great this was a great
fun for me
i love that yeah i know i saw that you
post on social media that this was a
delight in every way so it sounds like a
good experience it was it just was
uh you know at the premiere on the red
carpet this week you said that you would
be
up for seeing a friend's reboot if it
was a whole new cast and it was all
about the now
uh have you thought of any actors or
actresses that you would love to see in
a friend's reboot no i do i haven't i'm
sorry because i i'm sorry i said that
because now everyone wants to know who
do i think it would be
are you getting on with that question
yeah no it's okay but i just didn't
think about who it should be so i don't
know other people are good at casting
yeah yeah it's a lot though right
because as soon as you say someone's
name it's going to go everywhere so
yeah yeah it also doesn't mean it's
going to happen
that's true
that's true
um i'm still not over your romeo
michelle reunion at the sag awards you
know the fans want a sequel
that's what i'm hearing
the fans want to see do you want a
sequel sure
that could be fun
that would be amazing it was it still is
one of my favorite movies you know when
that movie came out in the 90s did you
know that it would still be connecting
with people today and that they would
want more no
absolutely not
i did not know that
i mean i know people are still dressing
up as romy michelle for halloween so
that's oh no
but i didn't yeah i
thought it would just become a costume
and that's it you know
forget that there was a movie
yeah you know when you read a script
like that is there something in the
script that you're like oh this is
really going to connect with people or
it was just a fun movie you're like
let's go
um for better nate than ever
is that right i know
michelle
oh yeah but i had played michelle in a
play i'd been that my very first
audition ever years before
was for
to be michelle who was just called
airhead number two
yeah for a backers audition
first audition and i got it i got the
part of airhead number two
oh my god that is so amazing and then
there you go look how everything's
comfortable circle
congratulations on this movie uh i loved
it it was so good oh thanks i loved it
too
i know
all right well you've been ever it's so
nice good so nice and it's i feel like
it's the kind of move that we all need
right now too right
uh yeah absolutely
awesome thanks so much for your time
really appreciate it thank you